Joe's in Omaha Nebraska welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show Joe how you doing Dave
better than I deserve how can I help
well here's the deal my wife and I are
just truly blessed I mean we're totally
debt-free which is awesome
but we've got four boys that are kind of
entering getting close to entering the
real world and all they ever have known
is basically kind of what we've taught
them in terms of you know steering clear
of debt and making sure you're conscious
with the with the spending my question
is as they enter real world what would
you recommend in terms of the
appropriate book for them to read or
literature to kind of reinforce what
they've known in our household but it's
just not you know dad telling them what
to do mm how old are they well I've got
two that are in college and two that are
in high school so they're kind of
getting getting close to like I said
entering entering the real world I used
to pay our kids $50 for a book report on
books on one of them to read and that
you know they're not to be a big long
complicated book report the only purpose
of the book report is to make sure that
it was accountability that they actually
read it and they actually retained some
of what it said and so I have a lot of
favorite books that I wanted our kids to
ingest before you know as tools for
their adulthood and so I used to do that
a lot I you can do that I mean you could
take the Total Money Makeover it's fine
it sets them up to do everything if
they're if they're young adults totally
makeover hood work just fine for that if
you wanted to kick it up a notch and go
on steroids you could pay them to go
through Financial Peace University got
it and you know it's a touch more
expensive but that's not the problem
you'd pay the hundred bucks that's not
that not the issue the issue is getting
them to do it because it's nine weeks
long and you know they're gonna go one
class a week for nine weeks if you can
get them to do that
you pretty much sent them to financial
boot camp before you put them into the
military you know I mean you set them up
to win
and a lot of parents do that stuff a lot
of parents take their teens with them to
Financial Peace University is as you
know as they're going through it so that
their teens learn it I've talked to a
lot of people say you know I'm 25 and
when I was 16 my mother drugged me to
the stupid class you have you know and
that's why we have the high school
curriculum and now 46 percent of the
high schools those kinds of things so
you know just give you that but that's
kind of taking it up a notch if you
wanted to do that you could do that
Total Money Makeover though will do
everything they need to do in terms of
if they get it the trick is you know are
they ready to actually get it or are
they just gonna you know kind of a wink
and a nod towards the dad and move on
and sometimes that's what we all do at
that age